we're at the cusp of a technological
revolution change is always been with us
but the rate of change is changing it's
no longer evolution it's revolutionary
you know the trajectory is changing and
the momentum is accelerating its
acceleration and trajectory change all
at once and three dimensionally but what
you really have to recognize that what
moves people is not state-of-the-art
technology is state of the heart
technology the idea that this technology
is the cold comfort unless the engineer
can serve the poet and the poet the
engineer lesson is that connection
between the two technology doesn't do
anything unless it move something less
it renders the benefit unless it makes
the distances closer unless it makes it
more resonant more memorable unless it
unless it offers a deeper meaning to
your heart and your soul a deeper
purposefulness it'll be vestigial it'll
be gone so the idea is don't abandon
state of the heart for state-of-the-art
ask yourself a very important question
the benefit of this technology how does
it make us connect better I don't mean
connect technically better that's
important but how does it make us
connect better how does it get more in
deeper heartfelt connection between
people now I think a twitter is an
incredibly valuable tool it's a way to
send you know short bursts messages
information to people and really tell
you where you are geographically and it
doesn't mean that poetry has to be lon
but the idea is venerate the state of
the heart not just n of the art of the
ozen ones
Stan god of the portals of your mind
technology isn't an answer it's an
enabler it's an enable enable you to do
something better faster more effectively
more joyously you know if that's really
what it comes down to all of the social
networks are an expression of human
needs human desires that's why they're
so powerful you drive out of your house
today on your two miles down the road
you go like this not tell me up at this
what are you looking for now you're not
looking for your patent you're not
looking for a photo album you're looking
for your phone and you got right next to
your heart and you don't have it you got
heart attack you up and what do you do
you turn around you go get it why do you
do that because this has a bitumen that
this mobile device is at which is
tinkering with your neural pathways it
has rewired you it has gone almost from
a want to a need you are addicted to it
if not a bitumen it to it but the
reality is why because it is a sense of
connection always being connected to
your family to your work to your
business and do you joy whatever your
joyous you can look at your football
game you look at the pictures of your
family and very soon all your medical
and information will be on it oh my god
it's going to be your wallet those
little Benjamin's and those Franklin's
those Washington's they're going to be
gone going to pay for everything with
this new thing called a mobile phone
that is a transformative device because
of the way it's been absorbed into
society and by us individually and boy
you get total anxiety when you leave
that home or lose it and everybody knows
it